au camping tout est une question de
préférence entre les tentes basique ou
améliorer la lit de camp et les
bungalows confort chacun y trouve son
compte son compte de tranquillité malgré
la présence de centaines de campeurs
raymonde vient ici très régulièrement
elle a trouvé le bon compromis en cette
période de festivités
moi j'aime venu c'est pendant le
carnaval reçoit déjà c'est tout près
pour aller voir le vide et pour
participer aux manifestations qui est
pourquoi ici ceux ci proposent pas de
carnaval en revanche pour cette famille
qui a privilégie des plaisirs simples en
ce 101e ici c'est donc vite et du calme
web2 calmes et puis voilà et vous avez
bien on est très inquiet non je préfère
rester au calme ce cadeau là vous
convient tout à fait oui la nature la
plagne l'a vraiment journée détente
aujourd'hui pas de carnaval non plus
pour cette centaine de personnes depuis
dimanche ce camp de vacances
intergénérationnelle a investi toute une
partie du camping
outre les tâches du quotidien et les
repas préparés sur place
les journées sont rythmées de moments de
détente et de partage de jeu collectif
et de baignade et ben oui c'est pas par
hasard parce qu'on se dit que ben on a
envie d'offrir autre chose aux jeunes
pendant cette période
c'est vrai que le carnaval parfois des
nuits à certains débordements
malheureusement et on s'est dit que ben
notre jeunesse en vue on a envie de leur
donner autre chose et la nature d'autres
valeurs profiter de ce temps là pour
développer d'autres valeurs comme la
solidarité comme l'amour fraternel en
fait c'est ça après on a à être en
famille c'est pas confus le carnaval
c'est qu'on préfère se recentrer
sur des valeurs essentielles des valeurs
qui vont nous porter vers l'avant
on sait que ce carnaval chacun a pris 6
à son niveau que beaucoup parlent de
décomposition d'aller des complices ya
d'autres manières d'être des complices
il ya d'autres manières de décompresser
mètres de face on a construit de façon
assez conscient un camping qui a ses
habitués et qui rencontre chaque année
un véritable succès des taux de
remplissage record à chaque vacance
scolaire et déjà des réservations pour
les mois de juillet et d'août
le compagnon de beaujolais 2000 demande
encore étoffé à avoir des activités pour
que ça soit quand même quelque chose où
les clients ils viennent pour pour
chercher son bonheur la chaîne
certains ont prévu de rester au moins
jusqu'à dimanche prochain pour se
reposer après les vider